Ukrainian President Vladomez Zelensky
warned European leaders on Thursday
that Russia could attack other countries
if the continent wavered in its support for Kiev.
He said if Russia
had the chance to rebuild its military capabilities,
it could widen the war within five years.
Zelensky gave an emotive speech at the summit
of the European Political Community in Granada, Spain.
We have to win in Ukraine
so that Putin cannot scale this irration to someone,
someone else.
And it is realistic.
That's why the key things are our unity,
the UK and solidarity of all of our
Europe must be unwavering,
the unit of all 27 EU Congress,
all the Europe.
Zelensky added that he was still
confident of continued US and European financial aid
despite political storms in Washington and elsewhere.
And that additional military support to Ukraine
could mean that a,
quote, drone,
tank or any other Russian.